being a dad man how's that how's that
just changed you as a dude man so like i
said that's one of the the main things
that changed me and my whole mind about
everything because even besides the
group like i used to want to look out
for all my friends like
kind of be like a
father figure type role your family just
try to put everyone up on game once my
son was born i was like yo all my focus
and attention has to be on him i can't
try to look out for no one i can't be
investing my time and energy into nobody
else besides him like i got to focus on
him and myself yeah because i feel like
you know when you make it into the rap
game it's like all your homies make it
too low-key yeah yeah for sure and that
can also get
unproductive distracting
bad for your pockets
you know what i mean it's like yo if
every if you're gonna be around what are
you doing for me yeah are you the barber
are you the road manager are you
security you know
you just can't be kicking it we just
can't be 2k homies not for real like
like four or five months into my son
being born i purchased my first home too
yeah so i just feel like
once once he was about to be born like i
started getting my head on straight like
started figuring out what i needed to do
and where i wanted to be and then you
purchased a home on your neck yeah come
on had some